okay so the topic in this video is what
are stem cells but more specifically why
are they so controversial there's kind
of an argument going on in our society
and the use of stem cells for scientific
research and I really would hope that
you by the end of this video can
understand the controversy and at least
make a defense pro or con depending on
what side of the kind of the argument
that you're on I do not plan to give my
personal views the point of this video
is simply to educate I hope the tone of
my voice or the words that I use don't
accidentally let my opinions be shown so
let's go ahead and get started
so you think of stem cells well before
we get into the stem cells we need to
turn back the clock a little bit and
well here's a woman's egg cell and so
fertilizing the egg so here is a female
egg cell and it's haploid and if you
remember from science class you know
haploid is a vocabulary word that means
it's a cell with half the total number
of chromosomes that that a species
normally has and humans we normally have
46 chromosomes egg cells are haploid
which means they have 23 so in that blue
nucleus of the picture are 23
chromosomes and here come many sperm
cells from the soon-to-be father so here
comes a whole bunch of sperm cells and
in reality again men release millions
and millions of sperm cells sperm cells
also are haploid just like female egg
cells so there's 23 chromosomes in each
of these of five sperm cells that I've
drawn and so
fertilizing the egg well one sperm will
eventually penetrate the egg and not the
entire sperm by the way in the animation
in a moment you're going to see just
kind of like the head of the sperm will
enter the egg and the nucleus of the egg
will combine with the nucleus of the
sperm here we go in our animation there
goes the head of the sperm and the
nucleus of the sperm fuses with the
nucleus of the egg 23 chromosomes from
the sperm 23 chromosomes from the egg
you now have what's called a fertilized
egg or a zygote with 46 chromosomes
congratulations mom's pregnant
well that mods I goat that fertilized
egg that zygote is going to multiply by
the cellular process called mitosis so
for nine months that zygote is going to
divide and become two cells and four and
six and eight and so on so here we
so like it says the Myto mitosis is
going to divide the zygote one cell
becomes two two become four by the way
it's not a zygote anymore it's simply a
growing embryo I guess and so here it
divides again and divides again and
divides again and again and again and
again well let's zoom out a little bit
let's zoom out a little bit and see kind
of what it looks like in this early
stage
so when we zoom out we kind of see this
round circular structure and I want to
label a few things first of all overall
this round object is what is called a
blastocyst so the cells have divided
many times and it forms this round
object called a blastocyst it's filled
with a fluid that white space in the
middle is filled with a fluid it's not
filled with empty hollow air the outer
gray ring of cells eventually are going
to become the placenta of the developing
baby if the placenta is kind of like the
sack that the baby will grow within now
the lump of green in the middle that's
what's important I want you to pay
attention to this mass of inside cells
right there in green these are embryonic
stem cells eventually this green mass
will grow into the baby but for now
we're only you know perhaps are only a
few days to a couple weeks into the
development of the embryo so these green
cells are stem cells and so I want you
to pay attention to the green embryonic
stem cells in the picture what's so
unique about them well what's so unique
about embryonic stem cells is that they
don't have specified functions yet they
have the potential to become any type of
cell in the human body as the embryo
develops further and further and further
some of those stem cells will eventually
become brain cells other stem cells will
eventually become muscle cells other
stem cells will eventually become liver
cells but in this early stage they don't
have specified functions yet these are
what we call stem cells
so if cell division continues for nine
months eventually the embryo grows into
a baby
hopefully it's a healthy baby boy or
healthy baby girl ten fingers ten toes
hopefully the kid little kid lives
happily ever after
well let's kind of go into the research
now
okay when we look at stem-cell research
so during research so here was our
blastocyst again a stem cell might be
removed from this blastocyst so let's
remove one of the green stem cells from
that blast assist now we're going to
come back to this in a moment but
unfortunately removing that stem cell
destroys the remainder of the blastocyst
we're going to come back to that in a
few minutes because that kind of is the
heart of the controversy but for now I
want to focus on that green stem cell
that's been removed that stem cell is
going to be grown into a grouping of
stem cells so let's remove the
blastocyst it's sadly it's been
destroyed in this process so that one
green stem cell multiplies and
multiplies and multiplies and multiplies
and multiplies again this is all in a
lab now this isn't in a woman's uterus
or anything this is in a lab in a petri
dish we have what's called here a line
of stem cells if you ever heard the term
a stem cell line it's a small group of
stem cells derived from one original
stem cell
and so when we continue stemcells what's
so neat about them what's so promising
about them is stem cells are thought to
be able to grow into new cells that
might be able to replace damaged cells
let me go through a little fictional
example here here we have a motorcycle
accident and so let's say that a
gentleman a gentleman by the name of
Lewis was involved in a motorcycle
accident
and as a result of the accident lewis
sadly suffered brain damage you know he
survived the crash the helmet provided
him some protection but still the impact
was fairly traumatic and he had some
brain damage as a result well you know
let's zoom on in that to the damaged
area of his brain for a closer look when
we zoom on in here's what we see notice
those pink cells have a key that just
popped up those pink cells are healthy
cells and the gray cells pretend are the
cells that were damaged in the
motorcycle accident well what we what
we're seeing and why research is so
promising we're seeing that by placing
stem cells around the damaged area that
the the cells around the damaged area
those implanted stem cells will grow
into healthy brain cells hopefully as a
way to treat and I don't want to go so
far as to say cure but at least provide
treatment that perhaps Lois in this
fictional example can be treated and
have a higher quality quality of life
maybe regain some of the regain some of
his abilities that perhaps he lost as a
result of the accident so that's kind of
what the promise of stem cell research
is now in this example I had the stem
cells become brain cells but research is
promising in other areas
you know here's a picture right here and
you know in a moment pause the video and
kind of check out the chart in a little
more detail but here's a list of
diseases and conditions or stem-cell
treatment is promising or emerging we're
developing treatments and you can see
one of them on the list is traumatic
brain injury kind of like the example we
went over with our motorcycle accident
you know in that example I had the stem
cells turn into muscle cells excuse me
in that example I had the stem cells
turn into brain cells but again we're
seeing that stem cells can be can be
turned into muscle cells to help people
with for instance muscular dystrophy and
so there there's a great list of promise
that comes from stem cell therapies
so let's come back to this picture here
where we talked about stem-cell research
and so what stem cell research is trying
to do is we're trying to learn more of
the secrets we're trying to discover the
secret of how stem cells of embryonic
stem cells become specific cells we want
to know what causes some embryonic stem
cells to become muscle cells
what causes other embryonic stem cells
to become liver cells
what causes I should say excuse me um
can healthy cells can healthy cells be
turned backwards into stem cells and
therefore once we have them turn
backwards into stem cells can we then
turn them forward back into something
else of our desire now these are some of
the areas that are being researched and
again as I mentioned what we're still
kind of in the early stages of this
research but the research is very
promising so what about the controversy
we really need to understand that
so why is this controversial I kind of
glossed over it a few moments ago now I
really want to focus on that so remember
the egg cell at the very beginning of
the video we saw this egg cell with 23
chromosomes inside of the blue nucleus
well here come all the sperm cells again
five sperm cells each of the sperm cells
has 23 chromosomes as well so the egg
and the sperm are haploid cells and so
one sperm is going to fertilize the egg
just like we saw a moment ago and make a
zygote a fertilized egg with 46
chromosomes I hope you remember what
happens next that zygote is going to
multiply it by the process of mitosis
over and over and over again
so here we see the zygote dividing by
mitosis over and over and over and over
again then we saw this earlier well
let's zoom back out the cells continue
to divide let's zoom back out and when
we zoom back out we see that lump of
cells again called a blastocyst we saw
this picture earlier now we're going to
get into why this process and in the
root of this research is so
controversial
so during research we mentioned a moment
ago that a stem cell will be removed
from that blastocyst and and I brought
this up earlier but I didn't really
stress why this is such a controversial
topic in our society during the
extraction of that green embryonic stem
cell the blastocyst is destroyed and
this is where the topic gets
controversial the argument that some
make those who are against embryonic
stem cell research the argument they
make is that they feel that human life
begins when a zygote is created human
life begins when a fertilized egg is
created so therefore if the blastocyst
is destroyed that's the same thing as as
killing of a human of a human being and
so that is where we get into some of the
controversies around embryonic stem cell
research even though some very very good
therapies and treatments are coming out
of this research the argument is is that
perhaps ethically this is not a sound
practice because of the destroying of
the blastocyst now if you're watching
this video I hope you personally will do
some reflection you know look at your
ethics your morals perhaps your
religious stance and I hope you will
come up with your own view again I'm
trying to leave my personal view out of
this the topic of this video is
hopefully to simply educate
and so you think about well where do all
these research companies and
universities where do they get their
stem cells from well if you've heard of
a process called in vitro fertilization
you may have heard of a test-tube baby
well that's really what in vitro
fertilization is in in vitro
fertilization what it is it's a process
used by parents who are not able to
conceive a child the natural way through
sex for whatever reason maybe there's
there's some there's some kind of defect
either with the male reproductive system
or the female reproductive system and a
let's say a married couple is just not
able to conceive the natural way they
can go to a clinic and have what's
called in vitro fertilization done and
what happens during this process so
here's a picture of a woman's
reproductive system and if we look at
the two ovaries you might know that
inside of each of the woman's ovaries
are thousands and thousands of of egg
cells and so during the process egg
cells are removed surgically from the
mothers ovaries so I took about a dozen
or so egg cells out in this animation
so there are the dozen egg cells that we
that we just removed surgically from the
mothers ovaries well what happens next
in in vitro fertilization next sperm
from the father will be used to
fertilize each egg now hopefully you
know that when it comes to getting sperm
from a male you don't need surgery to
get sperm from a male it's pretty easy
to get sperm from a from a male so use
your imagination so sperm will be will
be taken from the male and will be used
to fertilize each of these eggs and so
therefore many zygotes are created this
is all happening outside of the woman's
body
it's happening in a lab dish in a petri
dish so again this is not happening
naturally inside of a woman's body
well when we continue to look at what
happens next what happens with these
twelve or so zygotes is eventually
they're going to grow they're going to
go through mitosis each one of them is
going to grow into a blastocyst so here
we have about a dozen or so blastocysts
well what happens next a few of the
blastocysts not all 12 a few of them I
have three of them pulsing in the video
right now three blastocysts perhaps are
going to be implanted into the uterus of
the hopeful mother so perhaps these
three that are pulsing have been deemed
to be healthier and and therefore the
best chance to grow inside of the uterus
of the woman so those three are going to
be implanted now the reason they plant
usually more than one is because the
odds of all three successfully taking
and growing into a baby are very slim
chances are one or two or perhaps even
all three of them aren't going to
survive and you kind of got to go over
then you start over with the next group
of blastocysts but every now and then
you know one of them might take and so
what happens if the woman becomes
pregnant
well good for her at least she's going
to know her and the father we are going
to become parents but what happens with
these leftover in my animation here in
my video here what happens with these
nine leftover blastocysts if a woman
becomes pregnant she doesn't really need
these anymore so what happens is they're
they're simply destroyed as medical
waste or here's where the research comes
in a lot of times these blastocysts will
be used in embryonic stem cell research
so this is where this is where you know
universities and private organizations
that are doing research this is where
they obtain their their stem cells from
right here
and so again keep in mind what the
controversy is again is that some
believe that life begins at the zygote
and therefore each blastocyst that is
destroyed is the same thing as killing a
human life again your job is to weigh
your own your own thoughts and come up
with your own stance
so let's wrap up this video and quickly
go over what is the federal government's
view on stem-cell research well March 9
2009 President Barack Obama signed
executive order 1 3 5 and what this
order did is that it removed funding
restrictions that were placed on
embryonic stem cell research under the
George Bush administration George W Bush
the second Bush George Bush to George
Bush jr. and so during George Bush's
presidency there were some restrictions
that were placed on the funding of
embryonic stem cell research with
federal taxpayer money and so one what
what what this executive order did was
remove those those restrictions on
funding and so this allowed more
research to be done on embryonic stem
cells and one of the quotes the comments
that that Barack Obama made as he signed
this executive order was that we make
scientific decisions based on facts not
ideology so you may not I you may not
agree with this particular decision but
this is our current view governmental
view on stem-cell research on January
7th 2013 the Supreme Court rejected to
hear a lawsuit that was meant to block
executive order 13514 Court refused to
hear this lawsuit the executive order
was enacted and currently those
restrictions that were under the George
Bush years were have been removed so
that really concludes this particular
video on embryonic stem cell
controversies again I hope I didn't
include any tones in my voice I sure
didn't mean to if I did I really wanted
to just educate and inform and allow you
the viewer to kind of weigh this
information and and take it from there
so I hope you found the video helpful
thank you for watching